APPROVED AT THE DISSEMINATION O
THOSE FALSE ALLEGATIONS TO THE
MEDIA.
WHAT DOES ALL OF THIS MEAN?
MATT WHITAKER, FORMER ACTING
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND HE JOINS U
NOW.
WILL, I THINK THIS IS FAIR TO
SAY WITHOUT EXAGGERATION THIS I
BIG.
TELL US WHAT YOU READ INTO
WHAT'S HAPPENING AND THE
INVESTIGATION THE TRIAL OF
MICHAEL SUSSMAN AS OF TODAY.
>> THIS TRIAL IS SO IMPORTANT
FOR TWO REASONS.
ONE AS HOLDING SOMEONE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR LYING TO THE FB
AND UPHOLDING THE WILL OF LAW.
ALSO IT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT'
TELLING THE STORY OF WHAT THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN DID SPREADING
THIS INFORMATION REALLY, THAT
WAS IN 2017 THAT'S THAT OUR
CURRENT NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR JAKE SULLIVAN WAS
TALKING ABOUT THIS SAME FAKE
NEWS FALSE INFORMATION THAT
HILLARY CLINTON HAD ORDERED THE
CODE RED TO DISSEMINATE TO THE
MEDIA IN SUSSMAN PRIOR TO THAT
GONE TO THE FBI AND SAID I DON'
REPRESENT ANY CLIENTS, BUT HE
DID, HE REPRESENTED THE CAMPAIG
WHEN HE DELIVERED THIS
INFORMATION TO THE FBI.
I DON'T THINK I CAN GO WITHOUT
BEING HIGHLIGHTED.
THE MAN WE JUST HOTLINE ON
NATIONAL TELEVISION IS THE ONE
THAT'S GIVING US UPDATES ON THE
WAR IN UKRAINE.
THAT IS THE MAN IN CHARGE AND A
LARGE PART OF OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY NOW.
MATT, WHERE YOU THINK THIS GOES
FROM HERE?
THERE'S ESSENCE AMONG MANY
WATCHING THAT THIS IS JUST THE
BEGINNING OF THE JOHN DURHAM
INVESTIGATION AND NOW THAT
MICHAEL SUSSMAN IS ON TRIAL WE
WILL SEE WHERE THAT VERDICT
COMES IN, BUT WHERE DOES IT GO
FROM HERE AFTER SUSSMAN?
>> I THINK IT'S GOING TO GO TO
BROADER GROUP THAT WAS INVOLVED
IN CREATING THIS THIS
INFORMATION BECAUSE IF YOU
REMEMBER IN THE FILINGS BEFORE
THE TRIAL STARTED, HE SUGGESTED
THERE WAS JOINT VENTURE OR A
CRIMINAL CONSPIRACY AMONG
SEVERAL PEOPLE TO EXECUTE THIS
PLAN OF LYING TO THE FBI AND
TRYING TO LAUNCH AN
INVESTIGATION THAT WOULD LEAD T
THIS OCTOBER, SO I THINK IT'S
GOING TO CONTINUE TO GO SLOW,
BUT IT INTENTIONALLY TRIED TO
CAST A NET THAT IS BROADER THAN
JUST MICHAEL SUSSMAN.
WE WILL LEAVE IT HERE WITH THIS
QUESTION.
DOES THAT NET, DOES THAT GET
CAST WIDE ENOUGH THAT IT DOES
LAND OVER HILLARY CLINTON?
TICKET LIKE YOU SAID EARLIER, H
TESTIFIED TODAY IN COURT THAT
HILLARY CLINTON SAID SHARE THIS
DISINFORMATION WITH THE MEDIA
AND REMEMBER, THESE ARE THE SAM
PEOPLE THAT HAVE THE
DISINFORMATION ABOUT THE HUNTER
LAPTOP, SO I THINK DURHAM IS
FINALLY GOING TO MAKE A
STATEMENT THAT THIS TYPE OF
LYING TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IS
OVER A